[Music]
Zayn Malik says he didn't make a single
friend while he was in one direction
sad story it's all in a new interview
with British Vogue the quote is this he
says I have always been a bit like that
though always a bit of an island I don't
like to confer with too many people
this bums me out just to be real honest
part of me goes hey if you want to make
friends you got to be a friend okay but
then the other part of me a second sir
Rogers a little tough but the other part
of me is like oh man I can only imagine
the experience of being a part of this
group and something that we view is fun
is work for them and so if well for
being isolated from all your friends
from home and people you grew up with
and just traveling around the world
sounds like a lot of fun but maybe it
wasn't we know but Tanner bands have
talked about this for ages about how
they started young how this is not a
normal life or experience for them but
when he says he didn't make any friends
where there was he not friends with his
bandmates like that because now the
apartment also said that she in the
industry yeah we talked about yeah so
I'm confused
let's break this down because I'm I
don't believe it I don't know
unfortunately I do believe it really
unfortunately I totally believe it
you can imagine well I think about our
pop groups in particular write on a film
set or on a television set there might
be a hundred people around depending on
the size of it or whatever but if you're
the if you're in one direction and
you're travelling around the world
you've got your Road Crew unless you're
on a plane or whatever but you're you're
pretty isolated is probably the the your
five guys and maybe a handler or two
yeah there's not a lot of interact and
they're working so much well the group
One Direction broke up in a 2015 and he
said quote Isaiah hasn't spoken to them
in a long time I remember when they
broke up that was like the break up
heard around the world for this
generation his relationship with Gigi
just yeah Zayn but his album so good
some of the best music probably came
from all of this turmoil always does
yeah but music always comes from a
breakup I don't know I feel like just if
you talk to people you're a charismatic
person just like
if you want a friend be a friend but
think about other groups though yes
other groups we're talking about say
from Ted or PSA from Tanner we got to
talk about fifth harmony we were talking
about them not too long ago about how
they're not particularly close anymore
do you think it's because these people
or these in these groups are forced to
be together be it these these reality
competition shows or well so I think
about it like this it's just like if
you're watching a scripted show if
you're if you're at home when you're
watching I don't know two and a Half Men
or Big Bang Theory and you're watching
this story unfold it's it's it's very
specifically crafted to make you laugh
or to make you sing along if it's an
album or a hit single and in your mind
you go all these people are all best
friends and they hang out off-camera all
the time and I bet they go get coffee
together and have dinner together and
and while yeah that might be true in
some cases in some cases it's not I mean
imagine imagine the people you work with
some of them you don't like but you
still have to work with them it's the
same thing for a pop group or on a
television show yeah I agree with that
as well and also when it comes with Fame
because think about think about it's the
solo NSYNC Justin having a very very
successful so extremely successful solo
career and also Destiny's Child who
there was so many members of destiny as
again there's there's latavia Latoya
Kelly Beyonce and then it had Farrah
Michelle ending with three Michelle
Kelly and Beyonce who all those girls
for years rumors of beef and drama in
between that but yet now as we know
they're still talking so I think Fame
has a big big big influence on these on
their friendships think about it like
this think about it like this anybody I
don't care if you're working at Walmart
or where you're where you're working if
two people are up for the same promotion
me and you we're both up for the same
promotion and then you get it and I
don't but I feel like I should have
there might be a very small part of me
it's like oh man why did Jason get that
promotion over me the same is true for
these pop acts right yeah well Zane I
hope you find somebody I'll be your
friends they will be your friends come
to your videos go on tour I'll pour your
coffee right what do you need man cream
birthday and I got you buddy no I'll
give you tough love advice yes your
friend your friend because you are
friends be a frickin
[Music]
[Applause]